this program is brought to you by Emory
University on the short-run mediators
tend to do really well and bring about
negotiating settlements but in the long
run the peace agreements that mediators
tend to produce tend to be more fragile
that is when we're talking five to ten
years out those peace agreements tend to
be more likely to break down and for the
conflict to recur that peace will tend
to break down because the parties
themselves aren't actually on board the
stakeholders haven't really fully bought
into the peace and only you know sign
the paper or came to an initial
agreement because their parties were
actually pushing them to do so and
sometimes it might actually be from even
a humanitarian standpoint a better idea
for the international community to wait
to allow the protagonist those that are
actually fighting to reach a more
natural point in the fighting for them
to be able to get to the bargaining
table the third party can't really set a
really narrow window of say you know
we'll be involved in helping to bring
about a settlement within the next year
or two that's too short the third party
is going to need to commit itself to
being involved five ten fifteen twenty
years as a guarantor of the of any
agreement that has actually reached in
the last year or so with the relative
success of the surge I think the US has
finally got to that point work can
actually think about the Taliban as a
negotiating partner where the Taliban
might actually want to to get to a peace
settlement the US needs and then the
NATO allies need to basically back off a
little bit and allow the peace process
to go forward while insuring as much
security as that as they possibly can
use NATO to an Gaddafi's rule but then
to maybe bring in another party a true
third party that actually hasn't been
part of the the fighting and that party
I think will be more credible at the
bargaining table to actually allow the
Libyans to reach an agreement that's
going to last five ten twenty hopefully
however many years into the future
I think the key there is to maybe put
more leverage on the Palestinians to get
Hamas to renounce terrorism to renounce
violence
as well as to accept Israel's right to
exist then I think we get a stronger
unity government amongst the
Palestinians that can actually then sit
down at the negotiating table with
Israel and then we can start worrying
about what the future actually looks
like and what's going to happen with the
settlements and what's going to happen
with refugees and and the right of
return the preceding program is
copyrighted by Emory University